hello and welcome to Beth Rigby
interviews where I speak to influential
figures who have something to say about
the world today and how it's changing
this week I'm in conversation with the
actor Liam Neeson
from powerful roles such as Michael
Collins and Oscar Schindler to more
recent action work we reflect on a
career that spanned over six decades
and we'll hear about his upcoming
Thriller Marlow the 100th film he's made
I hear the view are looking for someone
we're all looking for someone I'll pay
you a thousand if you find hands for me
the puzzle has many pieces I don't know
what you're gonna find
I'm going down the rabbit hole I'm not
afraid to take you with me I do like
this thing about not being afraid
you should be
Liam Neeson there on the big screen but
he started his career on stage back home
in Northern Ireland as a time of fear
and uncertainty we're here how acting
provided Nissan a Lifeline growing up
during the troubles
[Music]
and hit a message of defiance after the
recent shooting of a police officer in
Omar
did it make you fear that the peace
process was becoming ruptured no no I
did think there's a few Cowboys out
there the peace process is here to stay
it is
[Music]
lots more on that issue to come
including some interesting thoughts on
the possibility of seeing a United
Island in his lifetime but I started
with that major milestone in Nissan's
career
Liam we're speaking at you ahead of the
release of Marlow it's your 100th film
you've clocked up more films than you've
been alive the years you've been alive
it's quite something it's a credible
milestone for any actor how does it feel
to hit that number
kind of unbelievable
told me this a few months ago you know
Marlo that's your 100th film
it says it couldn't be it says yeah it
is
and um
some nights I lay in bed and try and
think of them you know
I get to maybe 75 that's about it
there's a few documentaries in there too
it is an incredible work rate though
yeah I guess it is look I've been so
lagging seriously from day one
and uh I sometimes say nip myself
because because of my luck
I'm gonna get into other films later but
just quickly which of your hundred can
you pick a favorite was that an
impossible question there's a there's a
few
um and for different reasons you know
Michael Collins I'm I'm still very
attached to you at least because it took
12 13 years
for Neil Jordan for to get the money to
make it because there was a war going on
in the north of Ireland you know
um
and Schindler's List too
um not so much for my acting but I
thought Stephen made quite an
extraordinary
film brilliant film really really
extraordinary and uh
the gray I finished one last year called
Thug for a wonderful Norwegian director
Hans bitter moland
who might work with before
um I think that's going to be a good
film
I'm a Hitman who's suffering from
from a brain disease
the old days it was called been Punchy
you know boxers got it
so that was that was interesting to play
you know oh it's incredible I mean it's
incredible but in your latest film you
play the character Philip Marlowe and
the famous detective created by Roman
Chandler and it's a character that's
been played before by some big Hollywood
greats such as Humphrey Bogart
do you
look at how other people have done it
while you prepare or do you
not do that I I I've watched I've in
preparation I watched Maybe
certainly more than 10 Noir film Noir
movies John Garfield Alan Ladd Mr Bogart
of course uh Robert Mitchum Elliott
Gould played an extraordinary one for uh
1973 the long goodbye Robert Altman
movie terrific film so I yeah I watched
them for a bit of inspiration and
you know uh Robert Mitchum played it as
Robert Mitchum and Bogart played it as
Beau Garden I thought well I'm going to
play this Liam Neeson why do you raise
the possibility that Peterson is alive
when I so clearly saw him dead someone
may have seen him recently in the street
and where was this
supposedly
I can't tell you
Goodbye Mr Marlow
I'm sorry that it was ultimately
uninteresting to talk to you
but I do like this thing that you have
about not being afraid you should be
I'll see myself out
it's your fourth film with Irish
director Neil Jordan it's a working
relationship stretches back four decades
and it's seen you in high profile roles
such as Michael Collins the
Revolutionary he fought for Irish
Independence once you put the success of
the partnership between you and Neil
down to
um well I met Neil when we were shooting
John borman's Excalibur
1979 1980 I think it was and um
Neil was commissioned by John to make a
documentary of the making of it you know
so that's my first
uh really kind of got to know Neil and
um
yeah it's been over it's been over 40
years and we have it's lovely me right
it's we have a kind of shorthand
language you know we don't
uh intellectualize a part or a scene you
know I we just have a short-haired
language and we just get on and
I think he's a remarkable director and a
remarkable writer too
I'm quite a good jazz pianist as well
you know
um we just get on you know I
I get them I think I think he gets me he
gets you and that makes it work in terms
of the writing and the parts and the way
sure you put the films together yeah
yeah I think so Stephen Ray Steven has
made 11 12 films with Neil you know
um but before I'm we're planning another
one hopefully at the end of this year
but a fictitious escape from Rikers
Island in New York which is an Infamous
prison
in fact it's so Infamous they're going
to knock it down I believe in the next
four or five years
so you've got another project yeah yeah
it's never stop to you
um going back to Schindler's List which
I I mean it won an Oscar you were six or
seven yeah one better picture and you
were shortlisted weren't you you won an
Oscar nomination for your performance uh
I was nominated yeah yeah yeah that must
have felt great huh it did yeah it did
um
I
I have thoughts about my own performance
and that but
uh but Stephen made an extraordinary
film I thought but you've talked about
it as a life-changing experience that
film it was life-changing in lots of
ways and quite traumatizing as well you
said so you must have lived it a bit no
um
maybe a couple of scenes maybe a couple
of scenes I felt oh I'm okay on that one
with Rafe and a couple with their
Kingsley you know I thought Rafe was
extraordinary bands of band was
wonderful too
um
but yeah there was a traumatic moment I
may have told you before or told her
your your channel before but uh my first
day we were actually at the gates of
Auschwitz and the world Jewish Congress
did not give Steven Spielberg permission
to shoot in large fit here's the guy
that made Jaws E.T there's no way is he
going to touch are we going all I am in
the gates of Auschwitz to tell a story
so the art Department very cleverly
recreated
the inside of Auschwitz outside
Auschwitz outside the gates
and I remember that first morning of his
elves baby so bitterly cold it was dark
it was about 6 A.M
I was wrapped up in them big fur coat
stuff ready to do my little scene
I was I'd say the fencing was looking at
all the Huts that are still there you
know
and Branco lustig who got arrested him
his dad and I believe one of the British
person he came up and said how are you
feeling I said yeah okay yeah a little
bit cold but you know
and we were looking at the hearts and he
pointed to her they said that that's the
heart I was in
I said what
yeah yeah
that's five six years of age
I lost it my knees just went you know
this is real you know
um
it was a very
it was traumatic for me it was yeah
I thought oh my God my heart started
bumping you know but I mean that that's
that's awful story in that it must that
must have been hard to
um
and I'd never did for sentences I did I
didn't want to read there's so many
books written on the Holocaust you know
I avoided them
um because
in those years this character may not
have known about that stuff you know
and after the film wrapped I I still
read Holocaust literature you know so
much
but then I I didn't
but that but that film is it still has a
vital message for today doesn't it it's
you know a time when far-right
ideologies appear to be on the rise once
more
it's a very pertinent film absolutely it
tells the story
or one of the many stories of Holocaust
in a way that that is accessible to
people and endures right so
sure yeah I mean
this uh Vladimir Putin guys like
uh
evil personified I think I really do
believe that
we all have to be honor
we all have to be watched
people like that but Putin is is evil
evil
you started your acting career on stage
back home in Northern Ireland and you
performed during the troubles you lived
through Bloody Sunday what was that
experience like
um
it was
I'll tell you I've been very honest it
was a mixture of
Joy here again to be to become a
professional actor and to be working at
The Lyric Theater in Belfast and those
days we were doing a play every four
weeks you know
and uh
but there were a couple of nights where
the the theater would get a telephone
call and to be
to beat the bomb
and we'd have to go out onto the street
with the audience
and the soldiers came in and searched
and after maybe an hour say okay
and go back in again
so we'd go in and resume the play that
happened twice
when I was there
so it
it was dangerous but I I the kid I guess
because of my age and because I loved
what I was down I was I was just on a
bubble I'm presumably because you grew
up
yeah in that atmosphere of violence you
were it was just something you lived
with it yes we did and there was an Army
Barracks up down to the street too and
uh was used to hearing gunshots on a
Saturday the troops were practicing on
the rifle range you know
um
yeah when I look back on I think my gosh
and hitchhiking when I was working on
this bottling plant
in my hometown I used to hitchhike up to
Belfast
two three times a week to to our supply
I mean
crazy
crazy but I again I was in that youthful
bubble man I'm gonna be all right you
know for Ulster it's been five years of
funerals this one was for two Protestant
Brothers killed in a week when there
were no less than 10 sectarian murders
on the last Sunday in January Catholic
civil rights Marchers defied a
government ban on parades and came into
violent conflict with British troops in
the center of Londonderry
yeah
foreign
the aftermath of a proxy bomb Twisted
untangled metal bearing Testament to the
force of the blast metal flung at speed
becoming shrapnel causing fatal and
serious injury to the dozener so police
some soldiers on duty here the iuc said
tonight that no one should underestimate
the seriousness of the current troubles
Northern Ireland was now experiencing
rioting on a scale not seen for many
years
[Music]
Belfast
Birmingham
Brighton
enniskillen
shankill
gray steel three and a half thousand
people were murdered during the troubles
growing up in Northern Lights like for
many people the troubles
they might not have grown up living
through that time
what was it like living through that
time did you live in fear or did you
just it was just part of your life it
was part of my life
um
and uh I I did get a rude awakening
January 1972 I was coming from a
physics class Queens University
and I was walking up to the halls of
residents and I've suddenly surrounded
by like 100 students of
but yeah I'm going scabs scab scab scab
on the phone what have I done
oh
again I was just in my little cocoon my
bubble anyway when I got back to the
lots of residence I turned on the news
or something and heard about the Bloody
Sunday and dairy you know
I felt ashamed I'll be honest I thought
I have to I have to learn something
about the history of my country here you
know
because I was ignorant you know and did
you go and I did yeah was it a political
Awakening it was a political Awakening
it was in many ways you know
and reading subsequent murders and
Horrors that happened
two miles two and a half miles away from
Queen's University but when I was there
1971 72 you know
saying oh my
God you you've actually what Good Friday
agreement
uh 25 years um
Northern Ireland and for bitter bitter
enemies
to ultimately come together and make an
agreement with the help of America of
course the clintons
extraordinary achievement yeah they had
talked through the night in 1998 an
unthinkable compromise hung in the
balance
I'm pleased to announce
that the two governments
and the political parties of Northern
Ireland have reached agreement
[Applause]
was all signed in that event yeah I was
uh
it was 9
in I remember I was certainly Living in
America you know but it had come over to
Ireland we were working on started
shooting Michael Collins I believe
it was just a feeling in the air you
know
of change
unchanged for good and change for good
but you have spoken in the past about
some of the experiences
of growing up in that
tense and violent atmosphere and you've
spoken about you and your three sisters
all suffering
from PTSD from some of these experiences
I guess we still manifest itself for you
um
I don't
think so
um but it took a long time for my three
sisters I had myself to kind of talk
about
a neighbor a neighbor's tragedy
ah violence commissions against
certain Neighbors in our street and it's
like
uh
but but I think we did my sisters and I
both did suffer from PTSD I think yeah
because because you were you were you
were catholic you were growing up in a
Protestant yeah but it was
um there was no
there was no reflection of that in my
life you know there really wasn't
I had a good school schooling
um I was very aware of an awesome damn
situation you know
certainly when I came to the 12th of
July and orange marches and stuff like
that but as a kid we joined in them you
know it was it was a fun day you know
and it reminds me actually of dairy
Girls TV show
uh these kids growing up and being
youthful and talking about boys and
girls and the thing the way
teenagers do you know and yet surrounded
by this
this violence
army trucks and bombs going off and
stuff and it's quite a remarkable show
and
and my sisters and I were kind of in
that boat too I think I'd have saved
because I saved
I had no Anderson Johnny I knew nothing
about the politics but but I I was an
amateur boxer
that plays at school that that kept me
out of trouble you know
it was your escapism we'll just cut you
off the streets and it kept your way
from getting drawn into yeah yeah it
certainly did yeah
and many uh boxing events tournaments I
had I know some of those kids Belfast
they're no longer with us
because they died and tried to claim the
troubles you know I don't think of three
or four of them you know
but you did I mean that wasn't your life
and you it was my life no you you had
these these two passions and one of them
you've turned into an incredibly
successful career and you you just
talked about the the um Good Friday
agreement and the 25th anniversary and
you know President Biden we think is
going to come he's going to come over to
to mark this this really important
anniversary but last month the Northern
Ireland police officer John Caldwell was
shot in Omar
um it happened in front of children yes
did that what did you think of it did it
make you fear that the peace process was
become enraptured no no I don't think
there's a few Cowboys out there
still want to believe in the old Ira or
whatever the peace process is here to
stay it is everybody wants it
certainly in the north of Ireland
and
but you always get that don't you you
always get a few Curry boys you know you
do but I do I wonder too whether what
you think about this whether
some of the you know brexit and some of
the tensions around post-brexit trading
in in Northern Ireland and some of the
divisions that that all caused or
brought things to Bubble Up to the
surface again do you do you ever think
sort of UK politicians our own
politicians have been responsible for
stoking divisions
you're opening a big book there you know
I mean what three four prime ministers
in the past three years or something
um
I don't know where to begin with that
one
it's I try and follow what's happening
politically and uh
I'm from the north of Ireland of course
very proud
to be from there because I think it gave
me a work ethic to Protestants and
Catalyst there's a wonderful thing about
Northern Irish people they do have this
wonderful work ethic you know
but on the world stage when you see
what's happening in Ukraine and stuff
and there's a politician talking about
we have to get our sausages in from
Britain and to Belfast and it's like oh
come on seriously is this where we're at
there are bigger things there's bigger
things but I know the sausages are
important enough
scheme of things and it's being resolved
well yeah and hopefully the
power sharing Arrangement will get going
again installment because it's important
is they have to get back to work yeah
they're representing the people of the
north of Ireland get back to work you're
drawing the salary still
do you I'd move on for this but just one
more thing do you think
I know you've lived in America for a
long time but when you go home
can you imagine Ireland
reuniting the reunification of Ireland
in your lifetime or do you think
um
I think it'll happen
to you I think I think Britain will be
pleased
you know they don't have to put 50
billion into the
Northern Ireland ex-jacker every year I
think that's what it costs oh yeah
I think it could happen yeah but you
know everybody has to be appeased the
you know the Protestants in the north
around have a strong voice
I hear them I know where they're coming
from and they have to be you know
respected if there's going to be a
United Arnold their voice has to be
heard they have to be represented if
United Ireland comes about it well and
you know symbolically it'd be very big
moment when President Biden comes over I
think the clintons might be very far be
I know in the clintons uh came over it
it changed their lives personally and
politically you know that's such an
effect on them
walking up the Shankle Road hold my
hands
Museum had
the Lord joyous
that they were being seen
on the world stage
the Protestant saying Catholics and it
was momentous I know that for a fact
from Atlantis have they taught you about
that I spoke to President Bill yeah yeah
a number of years ago yeah had a big
effect on them you know
well it was cool yeah well it kind of
put and put put the people of Northern
Ireland in the Irish peace process in
the heart of an American presidents and
successive American presidents with
President Biden as well exactly and I
forgot to mention George Mitchell
senator who
is really responsible for yeah
galvanizing that peace process you know
um thank you so much for talking to me I
really enjoyed it
[Music]
Liam Neeson there on his career in film
well I hope you enjoyed this week's
conversation as much as I did and if you
scan this QR code on screen now you can
watch all of our interviews online and
all the previous episodes of the show
and if you scan the QR code on screen
now you can listen to the Beth Rigby
interviews podcast each week I take a
look at the highlights of my interviews
and there's some extra bits and pieces
in there too this week we're talking
about the budget that's on the Sky News
app or wherever you get your podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you to my guest Liam Neeson and thank
you for watching
foreign
[Music]